(vibrant music)
(creatures vocalize)
- [Paul] Welcome to Hanson Island,
a remote place on the
west coast of Canada,
about 10 kilometers long
and two kilometers wide.
This island belongs to two
groups, the First Nations
and the orca.
(vibrant music)
(creatures vocalize)
For most of my life, I've
had the great good fortune
of living here in this
incredible environment
and studying this incredible creature,
and it's given me a sense
of peace in the world.
I want everybody to have
that same experience.
(vibrant music)
(gentle music)
My name is Paul Spong,
and 47 years ago I was a young scientist
at the University of British Columbia,
and part of my job was to
study an orca in captivity
at the Vancouver Aquarium.
I came to understand that
orcas are acoustic creatures,
because they're using
sound to locate their prey.
They get what they need
to live from sound.
They should not be penned
up in concrete tanks
that deprive them of
the sound of the ocean
that they were born into.
Ultimately, that knowledge
led me to search for a place
in the wild where I could study orcas
totally without interfering with them,
and that search led me to Hanson Island,
where I set up OrcaLab.
We built a network of
half a dozen hydrophones
that cover 50 square kilometers
of the surrounding area.
And they give us live audio,
so we can track their
movements, often 24 hours a day.
61 and 60 are there, I think.
- Yeah.
For me, one of the
greatest experiences here
is putting on a pair of
earphones and just listening.
And then we have speakers in the forest,
near the tents, near the
outhouse, near the camp kitchen,
all of the spaces around here.
(ship horn blows)
One of the things you can't
help noticing and feeling
is the sudden intrusion of a boat,
of a vessel, of a propeller.
It's jarring.
(something whines)
- [Researcher] What about.
- [Paul] Here at OrcaLab, we listen to
untold quantities of boat noise.
It's really annoying.
We can always walk away
from it, but whales can't.
It disrupts their communication.
It disrupts their ability to hunt.
- They've had quite a
few breaches as well.
- [Paul] Uh-huh.
I think, from the point of view
of the welfare of the whales,
it's something that has to be dealt with.
What I want to do is develop
the ability of the people
to get to feel empathy for the creature.
Since 2000, we've streamed live audio,
so that anybody with computer
access to the internet
can listen to exactly what
we listen to in our lab.
- Oh, look, it's right up at the.
- [Paul] What we're trying
to do is give people a taste
of what it is to be an orca in
this magnificent environment.
In doing that, they will come to care
and want to protect nature.
I believe that if I can share
what I have experienced,
the world could know peace.
(gentle music)
(creatures vocalize)